I want to do everything with him every
day so anytime we can be together
perform write songs hang out watch TV
whatever it is I'm all about Blake Gwen
Stefani and Blake Shelton's love story
is something to admire and talk about
cute moments how
about me and Blake next to each other
too much trouble you guys can't resist
each other Keep Your Hands to Yourself
Blake and Gwen met as co-judges on the
reality singing competition the voice in
2014. check out Gwen's selfie of the two
smiling from ear to ear fast forward to
2015 Gwen filed for divorce from Bush
lead vocalist Gavin Rossdale and Blake
ended his marriage to country singer
Miranda Lambert the timing seemingly
brought Blake and Gwen closer together
both of our lives have basically Fallen
completely apart and uh and little did
we know it happened to both of us at the
same time somewhere in in that you know
that time of of just you know Darkness
was this ended up being the greatest
moment of my life that same year Blake
and Gwen officially started dating and
one of the ways Blake showed his
appreciation was by buying Gwen a horse
I actually got her horse and and I got
myself a horse at the same time I just
feel like I'm in a dream when she she
loves riding and she loves horses and
and it's actually it's so funny that
people are so shocked by that but if you
can name me one girl on the planet that
doesn't love horses or just think that
they're beautiful you know and before
Blake was crowned sexiest man alive in
2017 Gwen let the world know that he's
well well deserving of the title I think
somebody that can make you laugh
constantly is very sexy and somebody
that is
let's see humble kind down to earth
selfless talented on the top of their
game should I keep going
no need Gwen because this next moment is
a heart Tucker
[Music]
in 2017 the couple released their
holiday duet you make it feel like
Christmas and perform the hit together
on the boys
[Music]
even to make it feel like Christmas
it's one of those once in a lifetime you
know moments following their Christmas
single Blake and Gwen released nobody
but you which premiered on Shelton's
2019 album fully loaded god's country
talk about pouring love into the music
[Music]
[Applause]
more grateful than ever I mean truly we
do the two were engaged in October 2020
with Gwen sharing this photo alongside
the caption quote yes please I think I'm
his biggest fan Gwen and Blake said
their eye dues the next year at the
country singers Oklahoma Ranch over the
Fourth of July weekend Gwen raved over
their special day on an episode of Ellen
it was just and not just the wedding but
the marriage is so fun and I'm so into
it so I feel very blessed Blake even
wrote and performed a song for Gwen on
their wedding day called we can reach
the Stars
it's very emotional nowadays they're
reflecting on happy memories Gwen shared
a Bittersweet moment with Blake exiting
the voice after 23 Seasons incredible
Miracles came out of being on the show
for me so I just feel so blessed that I
got this whole experience and got that
whoa boom and when it comes to the
secret of their happy Union the Stars
say it's simple I can't believe you guys
have been together for seven years so
fast what's the key guys I don't know if
there's I don't know what the secret is
there isn't it's just our best friends
foreign